[Music]
[Music]
yeah sweet indeed
hey folks happy Friday hello I'm Eric
that's John Luke we're a little late
today normally we're live at 11 I was
struggling for games but it turns out I
kinda knew already but Devil May Cry
came out in the u.s. US October 16th of
2001 so we were playing Devil May Cry
the HD collection 16 years later looks
pretty good
obviously you know this is age not the
original version it's the HD version but
we'll be doing that today John Luke's
gonna be controlling the game not played
the original don't make rye
all good I wouldn't I wouldn't have done
any better but it is very nostalgic for
me because I really liked DMC and I saw
a lot of people in chat already and
YouTube chat and twitch chat talking
about DM C DM c3 and EMC [ __ ] so all
fun times glad you guys can all tune in
it's weird though because so like in
certain cases the game will go like four
three but in like during the gameplay
and stuff it'll stay like sixteen by
nine which is good oh is that like to
get like a new feel like it's like a new
response powers yeah yeah yeah you got
like Stinger eight or something yeah you
see it's all coming back to us then you
got that this was like one of those
things where you got the cool like
stylish meter you know you'll see that
on the top right here in a second glad
you guys get all tuned in you guys have
questions or just want to chat about DMC
obviously I'll be in the YouTube chat
and put chat as well kampot so we
appreciate you guys all hanging out with
us oh yeah you're dull right now though
you got to get real cool John Luke is
there higher than cannot be higher than
cool right but was there only cool and
oh no
yeah I haven't seen you get higher than
cool so far
for whatever reason but maybe that'll
change as you get farther and then the
screen work there obviously that's for
health red orbs to like help you know
there unlock doors or level you up right
yep so yeah they're playing the you know
first TMC but HD questions I mean
technically we could play some of the
other ones later but in celebrating
these 16 years I think would try to
stick with this one as long as we can
see if we can get some cool upgrades
we're starting from basically beginning
no I think you're doing fine you've set
the meter says we're doing cool it's
crazy though that those the orbs yeah
you got to kind of go fetch him all up
the gameplay or anything throughout tell
me there's there's no bar and in like
three I remember they had a bar okay
like like as your combo me yes when I've
kind of tell like I'm about to lose my
cool well I need to keep it going
how much as iterations come you know you
you get some new things all right are we
stuck I wouldn't be separate like
there's a lot of relearning going on
here
maybe that door yeah nope nope okay
DMC five please says Rehan parallax the
last team she was pretty solid fine I
understand
bayonetta 3 that would be pretty good
pretty cool I think Bayonetta is like
anniversary's coming up to actually yeah
the original Bayonetta though also thank
you to all the viewers watching on
Facebook hopefully you guys are as
nostalgic as we are about this game oh
yeah you still got the stinger Oh Bravo
oh we're moving on up I think you have
it's like variety of moves too right I
think that's what kind of October 29
2009 go-go-gadget man's on it so
technically almost next week it'll be
Bayonetta
giving us unlock that door oh the hands
gone I remember that good times
combo list this game sorry we don't have
the manual the game used to come with
manuals John look if you're familiar
with this menu and I can't figure out
how to look at my other stuff I don't
know I'm just like r1 l1 r1 doesn't do
anything left-right d-pad no no I mean
I'm hitting l2 to open up this menu ok
that's how all right if anyone remembers
or knows how to do that please let us
know so we can look at the weapons and
stuff like that because he will
eventually get a few other ones
introductory oh yeah yeah you I've never
been
we need more nudity and abs in the next
DMC sure console hot
say found one
press on the touchpad ah there is no
touch ps3 someone sent me the link to
the manual
okay thanks TTL agent I will check out
the manual right now there we go
wait was that deci dmc3 though okay no I
said ps2 be okay as DMC Devil May Cry
though that's not the right one Oh
didn't us anyone yes maybe I can okay
let's see let me see if I can just get
rid of that yeah everyone's listing you
the wrong manual thank you thank you for
the new DMC we tried using the d-pad
outrage Bubba that did not work power up
baby put up our points extra oh I
remember these
right
Devil Trigger
where does the is there another leveling
system for like there is rights like for
weapons and stuff right yeah well I
can't actually buy anything so alright
hello from hungry says Victoire kuba I
think angry what's up wow you're tuning
in [ __ ] where they are that's cool
thanks alright where we gone gellick
going this way alright a little light in
the darkness
you hit o first then you pad alright
we'll try that in a second - this guy's
got plot o absolute absolutely good ah
we lost a combo that's okay because I
think it's just a visual thing do you
think you get more orbs for getting a
feel like the bigger guys just give more
work
yeah like the red one is there the
harder one it's like time crises the red
ones are dangerous
oh that guy seemed to have a hat oh
that's a great move public helm breaker
for all those people that play Marvel
vs. Capcom he's still good and in
finance by the way this is a ps2 game GS
jr. Jackson mentioned but we are playing
the HD collection which is on and far
360 and ps3 it gives you Devil May Cry 1
2 & 3 right whoo absolute his s style is
stylish the next one who connects above
which is related
I think I think you're selling yourself
short
I mean it's about relearning it too you
know
it's been a while
oh look at that grab oh jeez
but I would like a green color please
Ericom was the sword and guns that's
right luck of the Irish 1977 the best
was like I don't know if it's in this
game but like maybe it's a powerup but
like you know how you spins the sword
and then they pop up then you could just
shoot him up that could be in a later
one though the original is harder to
find try Circle Circle didn't do
anything right this circle these messes
okay now d-pad slack tilt left okay so
there's nothing maybe I read that wrong
let's see he said circle and then okay
circle you hit circle first then use pad
that's what okay maybe you don't have
that yet I don't know maybe you haven't
unlocked it okay I can hear voice oh
yeah honest door oh yeah is that the is
that the heavy sword
yeah lightning baby you're dead now you
have his powers I'm pretty sure that's
the the heavier one right mm-hmm
asthma lasing says Alice are upcoming
still good your demon after all no
problem look at you just slide up the
sword like it's no no problem well I try
to pull it out when you could just go
through the whole thing oh that's just
that's a lot I'm gonna go through the
whole sword because that's that's easier
that's fine
totally fine
oh yeah give me that sword look how cool
he is felt no pain not as witty in this
one game fact says our one turns pages
in sub screen he tried that it didn't
work I'm gonna go with he doesn't have
anything yeah he might be able to do it
now it was with an alternate weapon
because he has it you had to actually
choose your weapon in this one right Oh
soon because you can't like there's not
like a quick way to swap between them
right or is there by now I forgot it's
been a long time cutscenes back to 4:3
see there's a menu right there there's a
hot maybe so and then you got the little
ruin things I think that's what that for
the devil trigger what like you see that
or when I don't know yes once you fill
that up right nope still can't sick
nothing okay well weren't you just
supposed to use art we tried that crazy
boys he literally just mashed r1 l1 in
this into the menus there yeah weird
whatever it's all good just keep going
ain't no thang
he's half devil half man yeah well you
know clearly it didn't hurt hell yeah
we're gonna take that key we need that
rusty key we're the bad guys oh look at
that shotgun or something
yeah shotgun yeah
now you can't you can't swap off evany
and ivory though if I can swap again
that's weird
what's up Luis Diaz you're not feeling
the graphics hit Etowah main or are you
talking about the cutscenes though or
this graphics with their door okay great
you're reading some books yeah and this
is 16 years old by the way so you know
just saying for 16 I think you need at
some point it's like I would be shocked
if like it cuz they're like a fire
weapon in this game
my logic would say that you just press
up so the menu goes up up on the d-pad
that does nothing right that just and
then he said use the r3 joystick you
tried that too that's where you are
right it's low or no oh maybe not maybe
that's where you need to go
but is he holding nothing now let's go
back oh hello
how's this weapon feel pretty good here
block forever
Oh dirty we got the shotgun don't worry
there's delay can pull yourself through
a sword but can't get stabbed to death
all right used orbs try again you got
three more john-boy pressures on Finn
Meharry saying first game I bought and
best I've ever played
I know just beat that it's one of the
one of my favorite old games with you
yeah that's true double-checking okay I
can't haven't played this game in years
so I can't remember anything yeah that's
pretty much where we're at - yep we live
in a classic but uh what are you trying
to do in the menu we're trying to just
see what items we have possibly switch
weapons anything basically forget like
I'm pretty sure like there's a playful
like level up other stuff oh oh she hit
the grab luckily green guys do you know
- Oh see there yeah Bob swing
yeah the hop-up swing into the swing
into the gun baby
l1 to use Devil Trigger yeah we don't
need that right now feel like okay
oh look at him go
okay
witching has done at the Statue - ah
okay yeah I don't want to double me cry
movie we can pass no thanks is that a
thing
I like they trying to make one like an
animal
yeah Oh see there you go so now you can
level up the sword yeah here's all those
hot moves you can only afford the
stinger level one though I thought you
already have stinger well now we're
broke
sweet it's okay we got stinger you can't
find anything there we go boo hoo on the
switch would be on the switch which is
in the photos upstairs when you slash
the photos okay pick up rusty Kiwi I
thought we grabbed the rusty can't grab
the key a game with Dante and Bayonetta
oh yeah is very important I agree
philanthropy aka Ben Jacob DMC anime was
great okay so it's actually kind of this
way
yeah there you go that's the combo I'm
talking about the up slash into the up
guns you finish the game with using only
stinger and no other thing yeah combat
still it was pretty fun for that for the
times though sixty years ago John Luke
pretty good be honest
my little devil trigger you're like why
not fill that meter up anyways and you
can turn it off
Oh
another verse did not like a good anime
said he got there Dante's bites wrong
oh nice got that Devil Trigger
Bravo absolute close close that's the
styling closest I like it you're
starting to get that rhythm though yeah
it's a ps1 game everyone go yeah
everyone needs to realize six when she
did that I mean the main room confusing
as Matt Arturo I mean if that bothers
you have bothers you I understand it's
fine it was just a reason it's a reason
to play the game so you know sixteen is
kind of a weird number but it's fine
someone said yellow door I'm a lacing
yellow door yeah yellow door I guess
then you may be the new cue you have
will kind of work out for you that way
okay well I don't know did you see a
yellow door
see if we can find it
Sebastian Medrano saying this is awesome
haven't played this in forever it's a
nice little trip down memory lane
maybe I'll just make Friday's throwback
Fridays with the caveat of some type of
anniversary that are really grind of
that one guy's years Arturo's we could
theoretically do it yeah cuz you said
Witcher one and then I said bayonet is
the 29th 2026 crazy okay bring back the
game show maybe Joey one day
yeah I mean it's gonna be a hectic at
least couple weeks coming up here a lot
of cool stuff coming out obviously if
you didn't know you know we got the big
three coming out next week you got
Assassin's Creed origins you got Mario
Odyssey you have Wolfenstein 2 so stay
tuned obviously next week as we're gonna
have a bunch of cool stuff we're gonna
be covering what games are you guys
looking forward to I guess is a better
question
oh is that the yellers no you ain't
thank you couple doors
Bob Bob come Marilla says Dark Souls is
the tetras of fearsome game
like it's more complex
is weird like you're still shooting ham
like it that should've kept your combo
meter going all right so see if this is
the Yellow Door that he's talking about
Thank You Malay Malay sing still knows
where to go in this game
oh man the plant boss can show up well
something's happening today retro
actively weird clean just like Virgil or
something Oh someone's throwing [ __ ] at
me I hear the music like it wants to cue
you to fight something nice got thrown
Oh
you joke
jerks
Oh like that oh it's like a combo
yeah give them the stinger
I cannot see what's going on Devil
Trigger yeah
when all else fails this cameras alright
and there's a guy down there but
whatever see above car I guess video
hunter D says one in three are the best
for sure go to the top and jump we just
did that but thank you keep the tips
coming
remember the don't sugar being that like
quick there's something there I think
you're gonna have to okay nice I think
there's something shiny though at the
end of the hallway I don't know if you
want to potentially scoop that up first
case
okay maybe not level of gaming we were
playing Devil May Cry the wall this is
the HD collection but we're celebrating
it turning 16 it's been a couple days
actually past that but still
revolving door Jon Leuer can you time it
oh oh look back in this room okay
hmm yeah it's the sweet 16 home I
should've did it Oh trouble
oh that Grim Reaper gonna show up
it sounded like a witch to me yeah a
little
it's a boss or mini boss Oh looking like
that looking like a boss
you look I thought we already have the
shotgun yeah okay oh you got to wit good
luck
oh it's more than that more than you
yeah there's more than two oh yeah that
will trigger can't see [ __ ] get camera
angled
oh dude am huge scissors I like it
alright no problem the first game so
goddamn hard says Felix Veridian it's a
reaper so far what I was I was told
mini-boss thank you uh Gerson come see
Leo this is kind of like a remaster
noise the HD collection yeah I don't
know if they're gonna do like another
one though I don't see why they would no
be cool they put this to the ps3 error
had so many like HD collections and then
like I don't know I wish those were just
on ps4 nice oh give them that that staff
yes see the spiders told us where to go
yeah ooh mission clear that progress
thank you for the help so far in chat
we're pretty average devil hunter yeah
that's fine that's accurate
still still training
liam cliff just wrote a lot of stuff and
I don't but you need a head out to take
the stairs up because there's a door
around the pump calcium that doesn't
seem like the right word go round it and
shoot the guy and answer the door that's
a lot of spiders that was a lot of
sweaters I don't know we're just gonna
keep going you know till we hit a wall
then that's when we turn back to chat
exactly easy automatic combo oh wow
play easy mode interestingly they make
you play the first two missions before
they activate easy it's like is it too
hard celebrates expires of devilment Kai
okay where's the celebration we're
celebrating it by playing at iTunes
that's how you do it
destroyable harder you even have enough
to know we need air raid I remember that
was a pretty good move
which is your favorite
then we'll make our game mine is dmc3
those Bottari I think that's yours yeah
I'm a 1 or 3 probably oh this is totally
a boss if I recall correctly or am I
wrong I just remember this room fighting
a boss maybe that was at the end though
pride of the line
I feel like there's a boss in that room
eventually we're not gonna try easy
Malay don't worry
stick with the challenge sweet 16 iTunes
sweet 16 awesome
[Music]
Ricky B 2 says spider fights that makes
sense ratio that would make sense that
it's the spider boss I remembered that
was kind of a pain in the butt to that
fight I try to check up on Facebook here
see if their hooting and hollering over
there
[Music]
okay
go back the path Ana's yeah some people
in the facebook chat also saying that
dmc1 was pretty hard to play yep we are
definitely nearing the boss room that
was a boss room as Steven and Facebook
[Music]
then you go back to that room go back I
think yeah
Joker hike Devil May Cry is great oh
okay alright still good alright I under
water time yes it's coming back to me
now this is dumb just dumb huh
take that skull
alright at least he gave you life back
take the lion's pride yeah we gotta we
gotta go back to get it though yeah here
we go yeah we're gonna fight a spider
we're being I'm being told tips but I
don't want to see it I don't want him
here I saw it open legs yeah I remember
this boss being kind of a pain in the
butt for from what I recall but we'll
see I forget you got devil triggers and
stuff we're gonna be fine
ooh what was that noise it's a big
spider it is angry
you're saying you got someone inside
that big
kind of touched his life as healers with
with your hand like there's nothing
honey play is thinking DMC 1 & 3 were
his favorite Oh with the legs really the
way Oh looks like the buddies
[Music]
yeah yeah there you go nice dodging
that's good all right oh you guys Lewis
dodge don't would trigger and hit his
legs a couple times that's what been
saying it's dodge devil triggering his
legs okay well just try the devil
trigger to see how that goes Daunte
why does Dante not have any fun now
someone else is saying his head is his
weak point why can't you all agree chat
you know information there's too many
different tips someone insane jump on
his back which one is it
replying to us
nice so far the head and jumped on on
him tactic has worked
he's now close up his tail out of fear
oh hello fellow gamer says I know his
weak point this is weak point that's
pretty fair and that the jump on his
back thing has been for sure really good
yet Devil Trigger again just so you know
not saying you have to use it tone 800
he's weak oh he's not that weak yeah
well cus like put his tail on his back
so I think that made it made it immune
at that point I think you can parry his
fireballs
we're gonna go with keeping it oh you
closed it up Oh nose up shop right now
you have to trigger again Siri unit
because I'm back to gaming who will win
we will hey whoever said jump attack we
got to go to that guy the head the head
would worked as well whoever said legs I
feel like he told us and I don't
appreciate it nor does he nor does
Gianluca that was a holy [ __ ] they made
this boss easier yeah I recall being
destroyed by that guy yeah I definitely
I mean I did not play that know what
bosses are about winning remember this
game being tougher yeah uh I think you
take that lion's pride to open something
another door I don't know you you might
know better than me I jump into the
water
oh no the beat yeah platforming yeah go
fight the skulls surprise oh wait secret
okay cool yeah that's it yep we meant to
do that secret totally on purpose
damn you guys for seeing legs come on
guys you're supposed to be helping not
trolling oh well you have trigger if you
need it I don't know where this bad guys
show up
oh it's a witch with the scissors said
it no help what do really gain out of
that some orbs that's it what was there
a prompt that I was there like a parry
prompt or something that's maybe it's
saying that we were supposed to do that
we didn't something specific very sure
yeah whatever whatever we're here we got
to where we like hey nice vitality yep
BAM boom and you get life full life nice
all right got the be whoever's campuses
I cannot to quit this fire hedgehogs
favorite DMC is for and v3 is most
likely that thing was all I was supposed
to get maybe three is the best what is
this this is DMC oh my crying this is HD
collection that was sort of playing on a
PS triple time first secret level yeah a
critical hit defeat it with a single
shot so you need the shotgun yeah
can you even do that here though funny
wants to tell me how do we switch to the
shotgun would like shotgun please
shotgun be able to do this that's fine
go to the yellow door again place of
life Ryan Thank You outraged Bella will
do that after this which decides to
slowly come down
at least you get orbs for this oh you're
just not messing around no no the door
with the jumping steps it's you know the
DMC creator is working on a new game so
Spartan I did not know that I guess we
could look that up well do you see
creators
I guess plans to announce a new game in
2017
so that's not the original theater
though that's the guy who was always a
Capcom got you
is uh so wait it's name the original
creator Kamya oh is it coming out or I'm
saying that wrong to you huh
I think you're right scale down rip yeah
give me down DMC give me Dante and
Dragons and work on Oh
where are we supposed to go he said
yellow door right yellow door place of
lion's pride can you go back through
there Bayonetta is the closest to a
devil make our game will get Sally it's
kind of like a slightly improvement to
the way you depend on how you look and
which time and all that stuff is pretty
fun yeah yeah I mean it's sort of like
the spiritual successor to now to the
lion door
let's go
you know me it wasn't involved in fork
and I know a lot of people really like
four so I certainly think there's still
talent that kept coming back and making
me deaf background damn Chris verdict
not a not a fan of the devil may cry I
like that one we cry I don't think it
was a forgettable franchise yeah I agree
Johnny Blaze scale down should have
gotten a chance damn it Microsoft I
actually I mean I don't know if I would
have actually done it for sure but I
just feel like I would have potentially
bought a yeah I would have potentially
bought an Xbox one for scalebound but
now that game is not coming out Ben
djenka saying I would actually say Ben
bayonetta is better than DMC pretty
confident in saying I also think it's
just the best action game I think when
people talk about best action games
they're either it's either Devil May Cry
3 or Bayonetta 1 it's like the two camps
more in alright yellow door where's the
yellow doors right there yellow doors oh
look I think you can go can you go in
the yellow door
he's back the spider line
pick a door man five day yellow door
right yeah shoot you think he's still
there
let's find out well that's what someone
said I don't know if that's actually
true we have to go through the Yellow
Door
I feel like it sort of makes sense there
we go yeah cuz remember like that that
thing you couldn't get through it
because you didn't have so yeah thank
you I forgot whose told us in YouTube
chat but thank you for that magical
destruction we'll wait
oh this guy was a panda right as I said
this guy was a pain in the butt
oh we got two more we can still we can
buy those right
yes all right try again
bless you this guy was a rip now this
this guy really cuz he moves a lot and
the camera is kind of like so ston foot
seven seven he says press right on the
d-pad while you're in the man you
switched to the weapons menu and there
you can change weapons we tried that I
feel like and it didn't work so he's
here you want to see full camera alright
go show them that you're actually
hitting right on the d-pad right no
right d-pad yeah okay yeah exactly
all right back to gaming pip sorry I
mean it's not like we didn't try
someone was saying that you can hit the
cannon ball back at the spider oh he's
got darts Oh
oh hello like oiled metal alchemist [ __ ]
where he like oh I told you I wasn't
lying when I said this guy was a real
pain but be alright only one more life
necessarily we have the heart saves we
have one more try again
it's Resident Evil camera because Capcom
what is the dude's name with the glasses
my name is wait
goddammit we're both wearing glasses
that's John Luke I'm Eric
I was like wait am i wearing contacts
today switch one says are three that
didn't work either what you can't see is
he's trying it he didn't bring the
control high enough for the camera but
man whatever it's fine alright there's
gotta be a strategy for this guy it says
don't rush and dodge yeah
damn it David
let's uh
whoo nice Todd no no
Wow
oh good god
and when his ball comes out you have to
attack okay
[Music]
guessing not though oh yeah always
okay all right we're learning we got it
thank you for the tips everybody thank
you thank you use your guns to wear it
down to expose the court yep we got it
we are dead but Dante is never really
dead oh good that's good progression
it's all about progress okay now you got
to avoid the spider again maybe I can go
right to the door this time yeah just
try to dodge and then go to the door
yeah
thanks everybody telling us we got to
dodge the [ __ ] out of the Panther
because we do yeah DMC 2 was not so hot
but DMC was yeah suck it yeah big spider
there we go
Davey said the dog was easy for him
because he wasted the shotty on him and
bam it was over
shotgun
hey like our gun just see the dog
Oh was that hot resident evil
yep
oh that's like that's deadly there we go
to get you all all right got him yep yep
no idea how but we got them and there's
how thing think thank you I'll take it
it's a cat dude it's a lion right it's a
lion / Panther no it's more like a
panther like as dumb as it sounds we've
tried every button in the menus and it
does not now there could be something
we're doing wrong and I wouldn't be
shocked but from every logical normal
thing you would do at a menu we've tried
and no worky is that a shiny right there
just a light
yeah everything I'm seeing for the knee
for the menu navigation is saying hold
r1 l1 that was from them so we can try
that after he does this but I feel like
we've been trying that unless you
haven't held r1 and maybe holding versus
tapping these different hold it no damn
it okay well uh trigger the door
upstairs well we just passed the door
we're gonna find out if there's another
door
there isn't okay we gotta get a key
probably in that door but that's how we
would have figured it out otherwise all
right
nothing like getting lucky sometimes
Dave Dave Duda I think it was Dave doula
on Facebook sighs love this game awesome
thanks Corey Green we kept shooting we
got it we got it yeah I can't tell it
which ones are newer and what gets in
the bottom comments are your go-to
weapons yeah we've been trying to go to
weapons
isn't there a menu where you can examine
your items and weapons technically yes
what's that thing in the
I think it eventually does crack open
immense power
let's take a nap if I remember correctly
eating a gem for that lock Thanks ducat
so do we need a head somewhere else son
[Music]
it's so weird that we can't navigate the
menus it's actually frustrating oh okay
well what was that okay hold on okay
this whole camera map but it's only the
map even though it shows those other
things all right back to game whatever
do it okay but start opens up items and
the map that's why that's stupid
all right well we know I switch to the
shotgun now and our different sword yeah
cuz you could why would you go normal
though right at this point but yes we
could go shotgun we wanted to turns out
we should have hit start this whole time
sure why don't we want to try this shot
yeah we nailed it
holy [ __ ] all right I think you need you
have to navigate it it's not Direction
it was just hitting start it was not the
circle button anyways uh I think you
have to go jump off the top of the
stairs really okay all right okay yet he
says jump off the top of the stairs I'll
try it
oh yeah shotgun baby and there was
health over there just be right now all
right well there is it there is a
section right there for you to jump off
the stairs Oh is there feel like we're
here what if we got trolled oh yeah yeah
there's there's a thing there there's
the thing all the way down there
well sorry what am I supposed to do when
I jump just like freefall Assassin's
Creed believe nice good work
what it that just brought us all the way
back up Oh nope there's something there
the sword that's uh into that thing
right no it was yep thank you oh I miss
Onimusha kids Island keep true it's the
key to friends that's where that's what
we just got oh maybe that was just a
prompt to tell you what to do what an
odd place to put a sword
you know it's fallen off that resin evil
logic
and we even stick the sort yep okay into
the chest all right got that bright
thing now that what was that don't come
through the mirror something like that I
remember the mirror shatters yeah
there's like evil Dante yeah evil look
Dante
uh-oh
who's the real party
would even has our trigger or is that is
that not what we look like in trigger it
kind of does so that's I think that's
supposed to be meeting me outside yeah
you come out this way to fight me yep
someone else said Virgo to Miguel for
beep yeah but it's weird like they sort
of don't really talk about on this one
that it's kind of like a weird you know
Angelo is Virgil in evil for yeah there
comes the most badass character of all
time
that's Malay Singh people do love Virgil
come out here by Dante I don't know
member we thought this that we think
this games easier
we ain't afraid of this again
does he have Soul Calibur
watch out yes second
oh god we've got tremendous reach I like
the double stigma account
oh man's got me
you guys weren't lying when you said
that stinger could kind of carry us
oh that [ __ ] hurts Oh cheap yeah come
over here he says okay this guy fights
cheap you see how he try to swing at us
the moment we got up there oh you got
him stagger oh pretty fair right now
pretty even
okay it's not that even anyone ooh nice
come this way now
Thanks
that is that's what I would think to do
here
oh you son of a B you would this guy
doesn't fight fair not only does he make
you come to him but then he like he
swings at you the moment you jump
through come on now 1 Virgil problem is
we haven't saved in a bit which means if
we fail we fail yeah well that'll be a
good time to end the stream yeah but I
feel like you're gonna kill him so this
matter
at least you can't interrupt them
that is a neat guy
oh just kidding he's got like a fireball
instead he's got something better than
uh than a gun
the other thing you could do to later is
you have to I think you have one of
those between stars to get help so like
in the worst cases you can slow that
we play
[Music]
come this way
isn't it a Virgil yeah it's supposed to
be that's what a lot of people say
Virgil 1 Dante 0 that's usually how the
story goes Virgil is better in Marvel
vs. Capcom 3 - but he's not in
[Music]
all right
Oh
we mostly want to buy yellow orbs to
stay alive in the game yeah I mean we're
not quite not going to be playing too
much after the fact
it is like a 16 year old game kind of
what's up program gee I don't think
you still got trigger at least but uh
this is gonna be the Cinnabon right here
alright that's good that's good
just gotta stay calm and cool right here
oh yeah just need it our devil trigger
we just needed to fight demon on demon
brother what I can have that
[Music]
I'm having a headache
apparently you can use the talk for
dealing Oh
according to Claudio I did I didn't know
that toast man axe can't believe it's in
16 years
yeah toast my necks are crisper era I
need an article for this if you have
time to celebrate 16 years of Devil May
Cry if you if you have time for that
oh we got a D D is for demon-hunting bow
yeah I think we can play a little bit
more than call it a shame we'll see
where what this next area is like check
it out
what did you think of black-haired Dante
I have no issue
alright guiding of the soda even have
anything you want to buy
what about round trip
I think that's no is that the one we
spin around no stingers stingers life
whoo look at that it's going crazy now
the melancholy soul oh no is it another
dose Oh start me right off
and what happens is shotgun owning this
guy David
Oh God we may not be as fortunate this
time around
that camera angle though
Oh
there we go
[Music]
I like the all-or-nothing play explode
here yeah yeah good job not going in
there that was clutch clutched it out
not through that door whereas I guess he
do have to go up for that wherever that
door is great job game
a lot of anger here for the team you
judge BMC but I think all the way around
maybe no no no no okay there you go it
is what it is okay class I keep thinking
that mirrors gonna break at some point
you got a timer I feel very nervous
about it good day madam that was okay
that was yeah man he reloads his shotgun
like a terminator
is there something in that room says
someone says go back a minute 18 is it
the Sun thing because it needs an
immense power
remember when you talk to this thing
that can you swing that the mirror I'm
making the stuff up right now jump to
the bottom other way what is the other
way okay all right there you go thank
you
gently put one on one together faster
than I did all right
mission clear damn success all right
what do you want to do here oh we got a
beat he's sick
damn B is for brave probably pretty good
pretty good time to stop it alright well
guys that was fun sixteen years now that
DMC's been out it's upon a little trip
down memory lane if you guys are trying
to play it and want something a little
bit more up to date than the ps2 version
you can get the HD collection which is
what we played that's on Xbox 360 and
ps3 so you still have those consoles
yeah I don't know but it's theoretically
possible it's on that backwards nah
maybe backwards for 360 or xbox one but
the PlayStation service called
yes plus now the streaming one oh no I'm
not sure they have maybe they put as
possible I don't know yeah although I
don't know if I'd want that because you
kind of want that precision so if like
your Internet's bad anyways yeah sixteen
years thank you guys for tuning in and
having fun with us next week there's a
bunch of stuff happening you know
Destiny's gonna be out on PC as I
mentioned we have three of the big games
Wolfenstein to Super Mario Odyssey and
assess speeds origins
you're also gonna have a history of
coming soon which is gonna be for
Wolfenstein and we're hoping Monday
Monday Wednesday [ __ ] should happen so
stay tuned for that if you guys haven't
watched John Luke and our Richard Lee
here I've done a bunch of history of
four different game franchises so check
those out the next dream we're gonna
have will be Monday at 11:00 a.m. but
until then we'll see you guys next time
thanks everyone for tuning in bye